P youtubers is Charlie so a lot of you
guys were messaging me about infinity
gems inside thor ragnarok there are a
couple Easter eggs almond explain what's
going on if you're new to the channel I
do Marvel and DC every week be sure to
subscribe to get everything there's
going to be so much crazy stuff
happening in the next couple months but
there were two really big things that
people were freaking out about when the
trailer dropped in one was when hella is
first taking over Asgard or it seems
like she's first taking over Asgard the
timelines a little fuzzy but this giant
blast wave washes over it and it's
almost like it's instantaneously being
converted into a version of hell like
you see Thor being dropped down in here
this looks like the domain that she
normally controls it looks very similar
to what happened when we saw Esau on the
searcher use the power gem to completely
destroy a civilization in that guardians
of the galaxy sequence of the carriers
can use the stone to mow down entire
civilizations like wheat in a field
there's a little pea coming on in the
other big Easter egg is actually a
guardians of the galaxy thing - I know
everybody's wondering if this films
going to link up with that because of
the two big space-based Marvel
franchises well we need to find the soul
gem but wherever it starts it seems like
hella is using power on a scale that
goes way beyond the odinforce here like
the odinforce makes Odin one of the most
powerful beings in the universe but we
actually haven't seen that on screen so
it's hard to judge the scale of MCU Odin
force versus the comics but Asgard is a
tough place they have hard core
technology so anything that would be
able to lay waste to it instantaneously
like this would have to have powers on
the level of the Infinity gem in the
funny thing is big coincidence Marvel
posted a soul gem explainer within a day
of posting the thor trailer so there's a
lot of things in the background pointing
towards the use in the presence of a
soul gem that doesn't say where it
starts out the other big coincidence is
that a lot of her comic book powers the
ability to Coll Asgardian Souls reads a
lot like what the soul gems powers are
the soul gem gives you power over Souls
so like when you see Heimdall fighting
this soldier here it looks like he's
been either turned like he might be an
Asgardian that's turned into
fellas minions or somebody that she's
pulled from Hell itself but like you see
all these beings here these fire looking
being screaming his Thor's being dropped
down so there's a big question as to
what she does with the souls that she
calls either she turns them into
soldiers like this or maybe she turns
them into mindless beings they did that
a little bit during the Doctor Strange
movie so careful for spoilers for the
end of Doctor Strange so at the end of
the movie all the villains get sucked
into the dark dimension by Dormammu as
he withdraws to his own territory but
they get turned into mindless ones that
his beings with his big eye in the
center of their faces
amorphous beings they're really
dangerous but they were normal people to
begin with so Dormammu is turning them
into his mindless ones hella might have
a version of that too because you know
in the real world there's this funny
thing going on in pg-13 movies where all
the villains are these mindless drones
they're kind of doing it in the Justice
League trailer too with the pair demons
like you don't see people's faces just
like sort of mindless CG creatures just
another weird coincidence but a lot of
Hollywood writers think that that's just
so that it allows the younger audience
to enjoy the heroes beating the crap or
killing people without feeling super
guilty about it because it doesn't seem
like actual people that the heroes are
killing so I know that sounds like a
weird thing but it's a pg-13 movie
phenomenon hopefully it'll go away soon
the other big infinity gem Easter Egg is
the collector so this one is a bit more
of a deep cut in the background of this
shot on Sekar it almost looks like the
collectors fortress is sitting here now
if you haven't seen it at Disneyland
there's a new guardians of the galaxy
ride that's called the collectors
fortress that looks exactly like this in
the concept art so the collector might
have a big tie to Sekar because he's one
of the other elders of the universe just
like the Grand Master Jeff Goldblum's
character the collector still has the
reality gem in his possession he lost
the soul gem that's with the Nova Corps
right now as the end of the guardians of
the galaxy movie but he still has the
infinity gem that was given to him by
the warriors 3 at the end of Thor the
dark world one
by to go in even though it's sort of
tongue-in-cheek they sort of told you
last summer at comic-con what's been on
Thorne's brain this whole time while
he's been hanging out with Daryl
it was mostly meant to be a wink of why
Thor and Hulk weren't part of civil war
but it also told you some of the things
that door was doing how precious Mjolnir
is to him which is why it's such a big
deal when it gets destroyed in the
trailer here in the idea that he had
come up with no new information on
what's going on with Thanos he just
knows that he's a purple man that likes
sitting down he has a bejeweled glove
almost already delicious
question what are Infinity stones a lot
of information and ideas and what I like
to call this will Clues speckled around
the place and who is the man in the
purple chair his purple is a magic glove
doesn't like standing up so it seems
like a lot of that information they're
going to be giving to him through some
of these other characters like the
Grandmaster pella Loki all the other
characters that have had interactions
with Thanos or interactions with
infinity gems themselves there just
aren't a whole lot of characters in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe that already
have information on the infinity gems
you either have ancient knowledge like
Odin the collector the other elders of
the universe or your allied with the
ultimate evil Pharaohs who's been
pulling strings from behind the scenes
this whole time are relics that predate
the universe itself what lies within her
appears to be one of them nine realms
and not eternal at the dawn as the
whatever does oh I knew friends before
creation itself there were six
singularity
then universe exploded into existence
and the remnants of the systems were
forged into concentrated penis infinity
stuff the interesting thing that they
haven't really associated with each
other yet is the elders of the universe
with Santos
they've separately been searching for
the gem so there's this big confluence
of cosmic characters cosmic ideas and
cosmic level power all happening in the
same movie so there are just a lot of
infinity gem things happening in thor
ragnarok but let me know if you guys
spotted some of these and how do you
think that hella gets her hands on an
infinity gem where does it start so
what's going to happen next is I have
another Star Wars the last Jedi video
that I'll do there's more Easter eggs
from the trailer yes there's Yoda yes
obi-wan yes Palpatine voice yes Journal
of the will so I'll explain all that
stuff when I post that video tomorrow
morning so even though there is a whole
lot of new Star Wars posting this week
and I will try to get other Marvel DC
Doctor Who stuff out so I'll post more
updates as I roll new videos out but
congratulations to blade Wilson you're
the latest giveaway winner please
private message me so I can get your
contact details and there'll be a new
round of the giveaway when I post my
next Marvel video but there's also Star
Wars giveaway stuff happening in those
videos you can click here to re-watch
the Star Wars trailer a billion more
times and click here for the last Jedi
panel thank you so much for watching
let's high-five I'll see you guys in the
next video
you